ce parking toute la détresse des
réfugiés de mario paul il arrive en
pleine nuit ici azapo ricci à 220
kilomètres de la ville assiégée
ils ont choisi de partir
individuellement sans attendre le convoi
sécurisé que la croix rouge
internationale tente de mettre en place
ils ont roulé à leurs risques et périls
on a eu de la chance
les russes ne pas tirer sur nous mais
les deux convois précédents ont dû faire
demi tour ce qu'ils étaient sous les
vieux
ruban blanc pour signifier qu'ils sont
des civils qu'il ne faut pas tirer sur
les voitures
le mot enfant écrit sur les pare-brise
pour beaucoup ce voyage c'est un adieux
déchirants
tout est détruit il ne reste rien de
notre ville
ce matin un autre convoi mais cette fois
ce sont des ukrainiens qui essaie
d'aller dans l'autre sens ils tentent de
partir pour mario paul chercher leurs
proches bloqués dans la ville cet homme
espère aller récupérer sa femme et son
fils
deux lots des boîtes de conserve
et j'ai encore beaucoup de choses sur
mon toit
les russes les laisserons t'il passé
c'est aléatoire il faut beaucoup de
chance mais aussi cette preuve sur leurs
papiers d'identité qu'ils habitent bel
et bien un mario paul près du parking ce
supermarchés transformés en centres
d'accueil beaucoup d'enfants exténués et
cette famille qui a vu le convoi de bus
bloqués de la croix rouge
j'ai vu au moins quinze bus mais il y en
avait beaucoup plus la roue tourne et
donc je n'ai pas pu monter un convoi que
l'on attend ici avec impatience